REBECCA MOORE: Thanks
everyone for coming.
My name's Rebecca Moore.
I lead the Google Earth Outreach
Intervention Teams in Geo.
This is a very special talk.
Welcome to the Shaman and
political leader of the Kogi
people of Colombia, and to
our friends Mark Plotkin
and Liliana Madrigal of the
Amazon Conservation Team.
We first started working
with ACT in 2007, almost
exactly seven years ago.
June 7, 2007, ACT brought to
Google the chief of the Amazon
Surui tribe, Chief Almir Surui.
And he explained to
us the challenges
that many indigenous people
face around the world
as their lands are invaded
for timber and for mining,
as their traditional ways
of life are under threat,
and as they struggle to maintain
their traditions and the links
between the elders in the
youth in the midst of exposure
to the Western world.
And ironically, Chief
Almir had discovered,
as the first member of his
tribe to go to university,
that Google Earth could be
a powerful tool in defending
the lands of his people,
and raising awareness
around the world of
how their territory was
under threat, and in fact
use not only Google's mapping
tools, but tools like Android
smart phones to empower
indigenous people to,
as Chief Almir said,
take their destiny
into their own hands,
and strengthen them as a people.
And in fact, through that
collaboration that was,
again, fostered by ACT
working with Google
and the Surui tribe has
now mapped and measured
the carbon in their trees
on their traditional lands,
and they've sold offsets on
the carbon marketplace that
is bringing millions of dollars
of income into their tribe,
and has enabled them now
to successfully resist
the illegal logging.
So there's a very
positive case study
there of the blending
of traditional ways
with modern technology.
Chief Almir actually
said, the time
had come to put down
the bow and arrow,
and to pick up the
laptop, in order
to defend and
strengthen his people.
So today, we're really excited
to have visitors from Colombia,
again facilitated by
ACT, who've taught us
that we're not helping.
It's not about Google giving
to these people, these tribes.
It's about creating
a partnership.
In fact, Chief Almir was
quoted in the press as saying,
the Surui don't know
much about technology,
but Google doesn't know much
about the forests, and we do.
And together we can form
a stronger partnership
for the benefit of
people and benefit
of the environment
and the rainforest.
So thank you for coming.
I'm going to let Jenifer
give a little bit more
of a detailed
introduction, but I
think you're all in
for a treat today.
JENIFER AUSTIN:
Thank you, Rebecca
for coming and introducing,
and for all your work
in this area with
the Outreach Team.
So my name is Jenifer Austin,
and I manage our Ocean Program.
And I'm excited that
Mark and his colleagues
are here to talk about
their work in Colombia.
So first I'm going to
introduce Mark Plotkin.
So he studied at Harvard
under Richard Evans Schultes,
and went on to study at
Yale, and finished his Ph.D.
At Tufts, where he
studied medicinal plants
in the rainforests
of South America.
And I first met Mark when
the first google.org hire--
I think that was eight
years ago-- introduced us.
And she said, you've got to
meet Mark, He's really great.
He wrote this
amazing book called
"Tales of the
Shaman's Apprentice."
And so I was like, OK.
So we hosted Mark to
come give a book talk--
I think it was eight years
ago-- and since then, it's
led to a lot of the work
that Rebecca spoke about.
So it's very exciting
to have him back.
And with that, I'm just going
to go ahead and turn it over
to you to talk about your work
with the shaman at Colombia.
Thank you, Mark.
MARK PLOTKIN: Thanks Jennifer.
It's great to be back here.
And Jenifer and Rebecca were
the ones who ushered ACT in.
Actually we're a Trojan
horse, because we
opened the door and all
sorts of Shamans pour out.
That's why we're here.
The power of a partnership with
Google for us is immeasurable,
and I'll give you
a concrete example.
Because when Rebecca and
Mark Austin and Shawn
went to Brazil, we insisted they
stop at the Federal University
and do a workshop.
And this is a quote.
I want you to remember this.
This woman raised
her hand and said,
why are you here with
all these savages?
And she pointed at the Indians.
And Rebecca looked
at her and said,
if it wasn't for
these Indians, we
wouldn't be here teaching
your kids from Google.
That was a very powerful moment.
Now we have lots to talk about.
And I really want to
turn the floor over
to our indigenous colleagues.
I will say this, that outside
of the uncontacted tribes
in the Amazon, these are
the most traditional people
in the Western hemisphere.
When the Europeans first came
to California 500 years ago,
the Incas ruled Peru,
the Aztecs ruled Mexico,
and the Kogis ruled
the Sierra Nevada.
There are no Aztecs,
text there are Incas,
but the Kogis thrive.
In the age of climate
change, these people
are clearly the
masters of survival.
They're the only indigenous
group that lives and manages
ecosystems from the snow
fields at the top of the Sierra
Nevada, 15,000 feet high, all
the way down into the oceans.
We never say or think that
these indigenous peoples
know everything.
Clearly they don't.
But as Rebecca mentioned, we
find that Google doesn't quite
know everything either.
And it's that type
of partnership
of you guys in the sky looking
down on the forest canopy,
and these guys looking
up at the forest
from underneath, which is
the type of partnership which
we consider the perfect marriage
of ancient shamanic wisdom,
and 21st century
Google technology.
And we're proud to
be a part of that.
Now among the many things
are here to do today
is launch our map
of Chiribiquete.
Chiribiquete is the
largest and most important
national park in the Amazon.
It's the biggest repository
of pre-Colombian paintings--
over 250,000 images-- it's home
to three uncontacted tribes.
So it's biodiversity, it's
art, and it's culture.
And it's fighting climate
change by keeping that forest
in place.
We have lots of stories to tell.
But most important of all,
is we like to pat ourselves
on the back and say, the
Americans at the Constitutional
Convention of 1787 invented the
separation of church and state.
Well, we didn't.
That was originally from
Iroquois Confederacy.
And if you read Ben
Franklin's biography,
you'll get more detail on that.
But that's why today you
have the political leader
of the Kogis, and you
have the shamanic leader--
or one of the shamanic
leaders of the Kogis--
he's actually the
keeper of the oceans.
I want you guys to hear
firsthand from them
and to be able to ask them
firsthand from your questions.
But I promise you this, you
will leave here frustrated,
because you will
want to know more.
And the idea of having these
guys come out of the forest,
come away from the coast where
they're protecting the coral
reefs, and be able
to address you,
is the type of thing in
which we take great pride,
and the type of
relationship which
makes conservation sustainable
and the fight against climate
change possible and successful.
Because we know we
can't do it alone.
They know they
And that's why they're here.
Those of you who leave here
wanting more information--
which I assume will
be most of you--
are free to a great movie
called "Elder Brother's, Heart
of the World."
30 years ago, a
British filmmaker
named Alan Ereira
went to Colombia,
fell in love with the Kogis,
and the Kogis came down
from the ice fields
and they said, hey,
what are you little
brothers doing down there?
You're making a
mess of the world.
Our glaciers are melting.
And everybody said,
well, that's weird.
That's funny.
Look at those cute little hats.
Well now we know what
they were talking about.
They were talking
about climate change.
They were the harbingers of the
fact the climate is changing.
They live close to the land.
They know more
about it than we do.
They've come back to
deliver a message of worry
and a message of hope, saying if
we work better with them, if we
work closer with them, and
with the other indigenous
people and the other
peasant people,
and form these types
of new partnerships,
there is hope for all of us.
But I'm going to turn
it over to Liliana,
who will act as
translator for the Kogis.
But before we do
that, I'm going to ask
Brian, our ace cartographer--
who I hope all of you
will meet, especially
the engineers-- who
will show a brief piece
that he just put together
based on the work with
the Kogis by using
some of your technology and
software here from Google.
Brian.
BRIAN: Thank you, Mark.
And thank you Google for
having us here today.
So as Mark said, I'll be giving
a presentation in Google Earth,
establishing the context of
where the Kogis are from.
Talking a little bit
about the geography,
and the culture, some of
the threats to the area,
and also what the
Kogis and what ACT
are doing to help
combat these threats.
So the Kogis are from the
Sierra Nevada de Santa Marta.
It is located in
northern Colombia,
on the Caribbean coast near
the border with Venezuela.
This is what the Kogis call
the heart of the world.
The Kogis reside on the
northern coast of the Sierra.
The reserve is just
over 400,000 hectares.
There's two other indigenous
groups within the Sierra
as well.
The Arhuacos and the Kankuamos.
They are very culturally
similar to the Kogis,
although the Kogis are probably
the most unacculturated out
of the three.
As you see, they have a fairly
large indigenous reserve,
but unfortunately it's
just a small portion
of their original
ancestral territory, which
is delineated by the black
line circling the Sierra.
The black line is a project
that the indigenous groups
been doing to
delineate the extent
of their formal
ancestral territory.
The white pins represent sacred
sites, which originally started
off at about 50 you see
here, but they've since
been elaborating into over 350
sacred sites around the Sierra
Nevada.
And they're working
very carefully
to try to reestablish their
control of those sites.
The Sierra Nevada is
5,771 meters high.
Just over 3 1/2 miles.
It's the highest coastal
mountain range in the world.
The glaciated peaks of the
Sierra Nevada, the melt water
from these glaciated
peaks feeds all the rivers
that flow in all directions.
And these are very
sacred to the Kogis.
In fact, the entire
highland area
is the most sacred
area for the Kogis.
It's where the Kogi
Mamos, or the priests,
like Mamo Chibolata.
Only they're allowed to
go, because it's so sacred.
Among the most sacred
things in this area
are the glacial-fed lakes.
These are thought to be the
daughters of the great mother
creator.
And they're also portals
to other dimensions where
they can communicate
with the spirits.
And as such, the
Mamos leave offerings
along the banks of these lakes.
They also collect
medicinal plants.
The Mamos are not only
the spiritual leaders,
but they also have extensive
environmental knowledge
of medicinal plants, planting
cycles, things like that.
So they are really the
most important figures
in the Kogi society.
So this being a
very sacred area,
it plays an important
role in many
of the religious ceremonies.
For example, the adolescent
Kogi Mamo apprentices,
they live the first nine years
of their lives in darkness.
And then they're brought up
here around nine-years-old,
and they are allowed
to see the world
in daylight for the first time.
It's hard to
imagine the awe they
must feel to seeing such
a spectacular landscape
for the first time after living
so many years in darkness.
So the Kogis live on the north
side of the Sierra Nevada.
This is one of the
most important regions
for biodiversity conservation
because it receives the most
rain anywhere in
the Sierra Nevada,
due to the proximity
of the ocean.
So the Sierra Nevada
has many ecosystems
distributed through thin belts.
The snow line begins
at about 5,000 meters.
The paramo extends from about
3,000 meters above sea level
to 5,000.
Below that are cloud forest
ecosystems, and below that
are transitional
rainforest extending down
to very dry, seasonally
dry, forest along the coast.
So the yellow line here is
the Kogi Indigenous Reserve.
As you can see, they have very
limited access to the sea.
And this is unfortunate
because the connection
between the glaciers
and sea is one
of the most important
things in their culture.
They bring offerings from
the sea up to the glaciers,
and from the glaciers down to
the sea, representing the water
cycles of the glaciers
melting, the water going down
the rivers to the sea,
then being returned
to the highlands
via clouds and rain.
So the Kogis are very finely
attuned to this cycle,
and it's because
of that that they
were able to recognize the
changes that were happening
in the highlands due
to climate change.
And of course,
tropical highlands
are some of the most affected
areas by climate change.
You can see along the
coast that there's
many of the Kogi
sacred sites that
are outside of their
territory, which
is very unfortunate, something
we will be talking about later.
Looking closer at
the Kogi villages.
The typical Kogi village
is about 1,500 meters
above sea level.
Most of the villages are
not inhabited most the time.
The families live in
other scattered houses.
And they only return
to the villages
occasionally to
participate in ceremonies.
So this is a photo of a village.
You can see there's-- some
of the larger buildings are
temples.
Some of these only
the men can enter,
but they all serve very
important spiritual roles.
These are some of the Kogi men.
What they're holding
is called a poporo.
It's a gourd filled
with crushed seashells.
And its the alkaloid
that triggers the coca
leaves that they chew
almost constantly.
And the coca leaves
are very important.
They provide many
essential vitamins.
And they also help
with the digestion
of tubers such as potatoes
and manioc at high elevations.
The gourd that they have,
it symbolizes women,
and the stick
represents the man.
And the act of
sticking the stick in
is akin to fertilization.
So the coca is an important
part of their marriage cycles.
And when a boy becomes a
man, he receives the poporo.
The women in the community
aren't allowed to chew coca,
but they're the ones
that harvest and grow it.
The threads shown here are
very important to Kogi culture.
Threads are symbolic of pretty
much everything they do.
Not only the threads
for the bracelets
and the necklaces and
the beads, but also
all the clothes, which
they make themselves.
So the Kogi Mamos tell the
rest of the community what
to plant, where to plant
it, when to plant it,
and they always stress
equilibrium and diversity.
So they make sure that
each of the fields
is planted with many
different crops, which
is a way to avoid risk in
the Sierra Nevada, which
is a very-- the weather
changes very frequently.
And so the Kogis work from
the highlands to the lowlands.
They grow potatoes and
onions in the highlands,
plantains, bananas, manioc
in the mid elevations,
as well as coca.
And in the lower elevations
they have more tropical fruits,
as well as cash crops such
as pineapple and coffee.
And this range of
elevations that they
take advantage of
for food results
in a lot of pilgrimages
up and down the mountain,
which is a very characteristic
part of Kogi society.
It's very common to see
them walking up and down
the mountain, passing
coca leaves to each other
as they greet each other.
The Kogis maintain many
of the cultural traditions
of the Tairona society, which
is the pre-conquest culture
in this area.
There's still many
remnants of this society,
including what's known
as the Ciudad Perdida--
the Machu Picchu of Colombia.
This is the Tairona
settlement that was first
inhabited around 400
A.D. And at one point,
the entire Sierra
Nevada was inhabited
by the Tairona
culture, particularly
the Northeastern part
near the sea, which is now
the location of the
city of Santa Marta.
So at one point,
this entire valley
along the Northwest
part of the mountains
would have been
irrigated and there
would've been scattered
settlements throughout.
And now it's major sprawling
cities, banana plantations,
and things like that.
Also notice the Parque
Tairona, in the front
of the screen with the
green line around it.
That's one of the most
beautiful coastal landscapes
you'll ever see.
It's where the
mountains meet the sea.
And it's also the
location of only one
of three reefs in Colombia.
The other two are actually
far away from Colombia,
so this is the only reef
near the Colombian mainland.
It's also of note because
there were several Tairona
settlements within the park.
And those are being
returned to Kogi control
after having been out of
their control for many years,
and victims of grave robbers
and things like that.
So there are four major
sites that the government
is returning control
of to the Kogis.
Which is a very positive thing.
Unfortunately there
are many threats
to the Kogi way of life.
The first of which
is-- this is an area
with a lot of carbon
extraction shipping going on.
So this is an example
of one of the coal
ports around Santa Marta.
There's not only
extractive industries,
but this is also a very
heavily touristted area.
There's resorts all
along the shores,
and they're building
water slides and hotels
on top of Kogi sacred sites.
And just the sprawling
urban environments
have really taken over
many of the sacred sites
along the coast.
Also notice, this is the
first coal port in the area.
It was also around this area
where just recently there
was a massive coal spill
where the company had
overloaded one of the barges.
And in order for the
whole ship not to sink,
they had to dump
coal into the bay.
This was one of the worst
environmental catastrophes
in Colombia.
It was recently outlined
in the Economist magazine.
But this was such a
bad event that Colombia
had to completely rethink
their coal exports,
the way they're regulating
coal extraction and everything.
So It actually
halted their exports
to the United States
because of this.
And they're trying
to clean it up now,
but they dumped so
much coal into the bay,
that it's pretty devastating.
And this is very close
to where the reefs are
in Parque Tairona.
Looking at the other
side of the Sierra,
there's also many extractive
industries going on.
This is Cerrejon.
This is one of the
major mining sites.
This is along the
Rio Rancheria, which
is one of the major
rivers that comes down
from the glaciers to the sea.
And also along the Rio
Rancheria is the major dam
which has completely
stopped up the river.
There's some photos.
So that's--
particularly the damn.
It's really-- the Kogis
are very concerned with how
we're affecting the rivers.
Not only at the lower
areas, but the way
that those changes are
going to affect what's
happening in the highlands.
And now looking at what's been
ACT and the Kogi's main area
of focus, is the coastal
region along the north
side of the Sierra.
So this is a coal port.
And a coal power plant.
And the port shown on
the left was actually
built on top of one of the
Kogi sacred sites called
[INAUDIBLE].
So this is the port
in construction.
It's now fully
finished and they're
exploring coal from here.
And this was the Kogis
trying to access this site.
And the police got called in.
You can't see in the band,
but this is essentially
a SWAT team/riot police.
They came in to
prevent the Kogis
from entering their sacred site.
Now in response to
these challenges,
the Kogis have been very
aggressive in trying
to reclaim their territory.
The Kogis are
extremely cohesive.
It's very unusual for
an indigenous group,
but they've managed to they
save up a lot of money,
and are working to reclaim
some of their territories.
Starting with Habatani Guaxaca.
This was a sacred
site that the Kogis,
with help from ACT and
the Colombian government,
bought last year.
This is one of the
first times that they've
been able to recapture
one of their sacred sites
along the coast.
We're also looking
at consolidating
the other territory with the
other property along the Rio
Jerez to the west.
So you can see the Kogis are
now able to go to the site.
They built a temple there
where they can have ceremonies.
They're also working on
cleaning up the beaches.
Most of the beaches
in the Sierra Nevada
are littered with garbage.
So this is one site
where the Kogis
have been able to clean up.
And it's an important
site, because it's
one of the major sites where
they were able to find the sea
shells they use to
trigger the coca.
And this is just the
first step in the larger
territorial process.
As you can see, there's
many other properties--
as shown in the
orange boundaries--
that the Kogis are looking to
acquire with the goal of not
only establishing another
connection from reserve
to the sea, but also a
corridor along the sea
to protect all those
coastal sacred sites.
Not only are they looking at
acquiring some of these most
sacred properties,
but they're looking
at working with some
of their neighbors
who are currently
practicing environmentally
destructive habits
around their land.
And the Kogi have found
that these neighbors are
very willing to learn to
manage their properties more
sustainably if they know how.
So the Kogis are
working with them
to better manage these
coastal properties.
So this is just an overview
of their entire territory,
showing some sacred sites
they're trying to reclaim.
And I guess in closing, it's
important for the Kogis,
for their culture, their
diet, pretty much everything
about their society,
to have this connection
from the mountains to the sea.
So we think there's a lot of
potential of using programs
like Google Earth
and things like that
to help the Kogis
do characterizations
of these properties, map out
the corridors that they're
trying to preserve.
And we hope to help
the Kogis reclaim
their ancestral
territory and protect
their coastal sacred sites.
So we're going to turn
it over to the Kogis now.
KOGI SHAMAN 1: [SPEAKING KOGI]
INTERPRETER 1:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER 2: So
good afternoon.
My name is Jose [INAUDIBLE].
I come from the Sierra Nevada
Santa Marta in Colombia.
And I live in a sacred
village called [INAUDIBLE].
And we've come out to share
the message of our ancestors.
KOGI SHAMAN 1: [SPEAKING KOGI]
INTERPRETER 1:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER 2: So for
a very long time-- 30,
40 years, we didn't want to
come down from the Sierra.
But when we did, we found
that the younger brother that
is non-Kogis, have
gotten really big.
And they've grown, but they've
grown in material ways.
And what they've done is they
haven't grown with nature,
with spirituality,
with the forest.
We continue to do that.
And this is why we come
out to share this message.
KOGI SHAMAN 1: [SPEAKING KOGI]
INTERPRETER 1:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER 2: OK.
I'm sure you know we're losing
a lot in this translation.
But yeah.
So it's going from Kogi to
Spanish to English, right?
And this is
following a protocol,
because even though he's
the governor of the Kogi,
the elders are the
ones who speak.
They always do that.
So he has to be very
obedient about that.
But what he just said is
that our creator [INAUDIBLE].
and there are other two
names which I don't remember.
[INAUDIBLE]?
Those are deities, creators.
And they were charged with
taking care of the planet,
with taking care of diversity.
And they were left with the
legacy-- a map, if you will--
of that diversity
that cannot be seen.
The diversity of
thought and spirit,
of being able to-- a map that
doesn't exist in writing,
in material form.
A map of how to
interpret the oceans.
KOGI SHAMAN 1: [SPEAKING KOGI]
INTERPRETER 1:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER 2: He--
Mamo [INAUDIBLE]
says that it is the
spirits of the trees,
and the spirits of the
water, and the oceans
that have conveyed to them how
sick the oceans are becoming.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER 2: So he says
that the younger brother is
able to fly, and is able to
have a lot of technology.
And they see a lot of things.
But what they don't
see is that they see.
OK?
So it would be very important
if you could have the two
and grow in that way.
Is what I am understanding.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
So it's those two.
Yes, you can do a lot of things.
But there are others that
you'll never be able to see.
KOGI SHAMAN 1: [SPEAKING KOGI]
INTERPRETER 1:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER 2: So
a long time ago
when it was just indigenous
people all over South America,
they didn't have any problems.
But then nowadays
obviously, you know,
we had to learn to
coexist with other people.
And so now we need to be
able to explain to the world
that in the sacred site, in
the Sierra Nevada, that's
where our wisdom, our
spirituality, our culture,
that's where these
things are kept.
And if we don't protect them,
we're going to disappear.
So we need a map to be
able to get other people
from the outside
world to understand
why we are important.
Because otherwise, they're
destroying us little
by little out of ignorance.
And so we need to
have those maps.
Now yesterday I heard that
we were going to a place
where they do these maps.
And I had no idea what it was.
I felt that it was maybe
there was this huge apparatus,
or a giant mountain.
I had no idea what to expect.
And I walk in here
and they say this
is the place where
they make the maps.
And I said, really, this is
where these maps are made?
And he says and so, we are
here because Lilia, and Mark,
and Juana, and ACT
are our messengers,
because otherwise we
wouldn't be able to be here.
So I was shocked that you
took me to my village.
And he says, I'm sitting
here, and you went down there.
You took me there.
So that tells me that we
need to work together.
So that people can
understand what's at stake.
[SPEAKING KOGI]
INTERPRETER 1:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER 2: So
he wants to end
by saying that he feels
really strange being here
because everything is so square.
No pun intended.
And but yet he sees that
you guys can see a lot.
And that it would
be really great
if you could work with them
in some really basic things
in their territories,
so that you can see.
And being here, his thoughts
will be here with you.
His way of thinking
There's some very
basic things that
can be a huge help to them, and
thank you for receiving them.
I just want to say, just
one little thing that Mamo
[INAUDIBLE]-- the way that
these people make decisions,
it's all by consensus, and
it's all by the elders.
And everybody else is-- it
has to be very deferential.
And Mamo [INAUDIBLE]
is one of the five most
knowledgeable Mamos,
and he is the one
that has a relationship
with the ocean.
And it was weird, because
another guy was going to come,
and at the last minute he
decided he couldn't handle it.
So we had already sent out
invitations with his picture
on there.
And then it was like,
no, he's coming.
So it's been really great
because sitting around,
especially at night,
talking to him,
he's able to convey
information and ideas
about the relationship between
the mountains, and the forest,
and the oceans in ways that
are incredible and fascinating.
So it's a real treat
having them here.
MALE SPEAKER: I have a question
about the Kogi language.
And there must be
so much information
encoded about your
tradition and the heritage
that you've been
able to protect,
encoded into this language.
And I understand that most
members of the Kogi community
are monolingual, and
right now the threat
is very low of language shift.
But I was wondering if younger
members of the Kogi Community
are adapting to learn Spanish.
And if that is in any way a
distant or immediate threat.
INTERPRETER 2:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER 1:
INTERPRETER 2: So
the way that they
manage language, culture,
and everything else is,
the elders manage that.
And it's under their care.
And they don't
put it in writing.
So the knowledge
of those who are
going to be knowledge
keepers and Mamos,
it's all oral transmission.
INTERPRETER 2:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER 1:
INTERPRETER 2: And you
have places like the cave
that they talked
about before, where
the knowledge transfer happens.
And they do like, reading of
bubbles, and things like that.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
What stressing signs
do you see in the ocean that
are most concerning to you?
INTERPRETER 2:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER 1:
INTERPRETER 2: So
the first change
is along the
mountain range, it's
just the climate and
how it's shifted.
It's no longer its normal range.
INTERPRETER 1:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER 2: So
at first he said,
we've been able to persevere
through a lot of-- climate
change is causing
a lot of stress
and causing a lot
of cultural changes.
But we adapt.
Even from before, when there
was war, and illicit crops,
and other threats, we adapted.
But now that we're
going-- this is
due to the Mamos
and the influence
that they have over us.
So I said but they want to know
specifically about the oceans.
And what he's
saying is that, they
rely on these sacred sites
for getting the offerings.
Because everything that they
use has to have an offering
when its used.
And so what they
are noticing is how
those offerings, those materials
from the ocean, are shifting.
INTERPRETER 1:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER 2: So
they have-- the poporo
that he has is filled
with pulverized shells--
a specific shell.
And that's shifting.
And so the minute
that those disappear,
they're going to
have to either adapt,
or I don't know what's
going to happen,
but that to them is fundamental.
And that's changing.
INTERPRETER 1:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER 2: And
so before, they
used to live a very long time.
It was normal to live to 120.
But people are living
shorter lives now.
And they see that as a weakness.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER 1:
INTERPRETER 2: So
they're finding--
they're doing these
surveys to recognize--
to do surveys of the sacred
sites along the coast.
And what they found is
that a lot of the shells
that they use, they're deformed.
Totally deformed.
Or huge.
REBECCA MOORE: We
probably have to stop now.
But I wanted to give you
guys all a 20% opportunity,
including Google Colombia.
That we're going
to be having lunch
in Crave with our guests
from Colombia and ACT.
You're welcome to join us.
If you're interested
in collaborating
on this kind of project,
contact me or Jenifer.
If you have any
time and you want
to get into using Google Earth,
Google Maps, or some whatever
tools might be useful
to help them on behalf
of the little brother
working with these
indigenous folks from Kogi.
So please thank them for
bringing the message to us.